the Joe Rogan experience don't want to
hear the truth about it we did one about
trophy hunting animals about how because
people young people get so mad I'll look
at this guy shot a lion right and the
truth is that in some countries not 100%
of the time but in some countries they
are effectively using trophy hunting as
a way to to protect the animals because
you know there that's how they are able
to sort of like monetize you know in
that place and you know get money coming
in in order to protect the animals and
they're they're very specific and
strategic about it and it can be part of
a good you know sort of animal
management you know strategy and it's
being used to some success you know and
yet people don't want to hear that right
it's still really hard that's a weird
one to me and I hunt yeah yeah I thought
that the whole the whole lion right well
what they can do is they can say okay
well we've got these elephants one of
these elephants is an old male that's
like killing the other elephants right
and if we organize these hunts where you
got to pay half a million dollars for
the right to even go in there does that
happen with old male elephants I know it
that was the issue with that giraffe no
this was the case yeah there was a there
was a woman who got in trouble because
she shot this really beautiful giraffe
it was really dark and unusually
coloured and it was darkness was very
old and older the giraffe apparently the
males get really dark hmm was really
cool-looking but she shot it and
everybody went crazy on the internet
because you know she was posing and
smiling with this yeah but apparently
that giraffe had to be killed because it
had killed at least two maybe three
young males and it was no longer of a
viable breeding age so they they were in
this situation where they didn't have
the money to take it and bring it to a
zoo somewhere yeah and the they would
have gotten money from having this woman
come in and shoot it yes what they did
yeah that's sort of that sort of the
idea you know I mean one of the issues
is if you've got an area where you know
one of the problems is you need to have
a reason for the people who live in the
place to care about the animals you know
I mean if it's just like hey
ovens are gonna roam free well you've
got people there who are like alright
fine so I'm living near some elephants
occasionally they eat my crops and shit
and that annoys me I don't really yeah
yeah I don't give a shit about that and
what that allows to happen is allows
poachers to come in and kill them
wantonly right but if instead ok we're
protecting them we have a revenue stream
right we get money when you know hunters
come in and pay a lot of money to go
kill one animal right now we've got a
way to hire guards we've got a way this
is now a resource that we're protecting
right and that sounds a little cynical
but it is working in some places and
it's both it's cynical and effect and
effective and we have a we had a woman
on from the IUCN International think
Union for Conservation of Nature big
conservation group talking about how
this is effective now in some places if
you've got a corrupt government where
there's gonna pocket the bunny yeah
that's bad right but the point is just
because the mere idea of someone going
overseas and killing an animal is not
necessarily the worst thing in the world
we have to look at the details the
situation and that's hard for animal
lovers to hear animal lovers don't like
to hear that
yeah they don't they don't and I like I
said I don't like to hear it I wish
people would just it just what freaks me
out more than anything is that there's
no other options it's not like a bunch
of people or donating a bunch of money
to keep these areas clean and free of
poachers and the amount would be massive
right we can we can donate money but
yeah yeah that that's the when you've
got a problem that big and intractable
as how do you save these animals you
know and against habitat encroachment
right again you know people want to farm
on that land people you know people have
people have lives right they're not
sitting around going the people in those
countries not sitting around going oh I
love the cute elephant like we have the
luxury to do they like fucking live
there right and so how do you get how do
you get those people in that society to
really protect those animal that's a
hard question to answer and some places
are having success with that strategy
and that's something that we can
understand we don't have to approve of
it in every single case and we can say
that's really tough for us as animal
lovers and in fact the character who I'm
talking to on the show says I still just
hate the idea of an animal being killed
right and I say yes so do i right we try
to dramatize that emotional you know
resistance on the show like that
emotional reaction that we
yeah I I also don't like the idea of an
animal being killed brutally you know I
think I'm uncomfortable with the idea
right but if my main goal is to preserve
the population of these animals over all
this other from going extinct maybe I
need to accept that this tough truth
that once in a time once in a while
one's got to be shot through the head of
the rifle maybe I need to accept that
really when it comes to things that
people don't eat I don't understand the
psychology like Michael Douglas in the
was that movie with Val Kilmer the ghost
in the darkness that the Lions that
decided to kill those dudes I'd never
heard of this movie too greatly the
ghosts in the darkness I feel like it's
from the 90s but it's a really good
movie about a true story about this guy
that they brought they brought this
Michael Douglas character was brought in
to hunt these lions that were
systematically targeting and killing
these workers that worked on this
railroad this team of lions worked
together and started eating people wow
that's great movie okay we're good it
sounds ah and they have to they have to
go for the Alliance yeah yeah there is
ghostnet darkness oh holy hell biting
tension that is a great hunter val
kilmer is looking good there those pre
fatso killer
enough to do is to good-looking guy too
handsome that's the problem he had to
just go off the deep end
[Applause]